l'association citoyenne citoyenne pour
Montigny autrement organise le lundi 15
avril à 20h au club le village à
Montigny une réunion d'information sur
la transition énergétique une question
d'intérêt national il en était déjà
question il y a 6 ans alors de la
campagne électorale présidentielle de
2016 et puis par la suite le Grenelle de
l'environnement un débat décentralisé
dans les régions a été lancée et début
janvier 2012 bonsoir Marcel Girard vous
êtes le président de l'association de
Montigny de Bretonneux on peut peut-être
préciser aussi ce qu'est la transition
énergétique comment ça se définit oui
alors la transition énergétique c'est le
passage d'une énergie à base de faux
cils à une énergie faite d'un bouquet de
d'énergie renouvelable alors les
énergies fossiles c'est bien sûr le
pétrole le gaz l'uranium qui est une
énergie fossile et le charbon mais j'ai
une question naïve est-ce que c'est
possible d'évoluer justement et
d'oublier ses anciennes technologies ces
énergies fossiles alors il nous faudra
bien les oublier quand on en aura plus
donc le jeu de la transition énergétique
c'est
d'anticiper et de prévoir dès
aujourd'hui ce qui se passera dans 45
ans parce que le chat le pétrole par
exemple on nous dit que dans 40 ans il
n'y en aura pratiquement plus le gaz
c'est dans 70 ans donc l'uranium dans 50
ans charbon on voit un peu plus loin
c'est 230 ans
du public ou pas justement à cette idée
de transition on commence on commence à
comprendre qu'il va falloir faire
quelque chose donc le jeu c'est de faire
de la pédagogie pour essayer d'avancer
vers vers ce nouveau mode d'énergie et
on va voir justement si le grand public
est prêt à changer de comportement à
adopter cette transition énergétique
c'est la question que nous sommes allés
vous poser aujourd'hui
les panneaux solaires pour la note
souple l'environnement tout ça c'est une
bonne chose quoi de toute façon ce qui
est clair c'est que tout ce qui est
panneau solaire ou des choses comme ça
au jour d'aujourd'hui ça peut pas être
une énergie suffisante compte tenu du
besoin je vois pas pourquoi je changerai
ça me ça me convient pour l'instant je
suis un abonnement j'ai pas beaucoup
d'autres solutions que
l'électricité ça aurait été pas mal avec
le chauffage à bois ça oui
à moins chaque électricité et puis
maintenant avec les nouvelles chaudières
et les radiateurs avec thermostat on
peut vraiment faire des économies régler
selon ces désirs si j'avais acheté une
maison je ferai ce qu'il faudrait mais
là faire des travaux non ça me convient
depuis qu'on a changé les radiateurs
qu'on a mis des radiateurs accumulation
qui sont électriques dans le nom ça me
convient
tout le monde n'est pas prêt à changer
on a aussi entendu qu'il y avait des
inconvénients par exemple en immeuble
c'est pas possible d'évoluer vers des
panneaux solaires ou de mettre un poil à
bois par exemple oui alors c'est toutes
ces difficultés qu'il va falloir
affronter bien sûr
il nous faudra économiser l'énergie là
c'est l'isolation des logements
notamment mais c'est aussi des modes de
transport différents on utilise on
essaiera d'utiliser moins la voiture on
prendra plus le vélo on se déplacera à
pied quand cela sera possible et donc
ici cette financer cette transition
énergétique les pouvoirs publics mettent
aussi de l'argent et vu le contexte
c'est un petit peu compliqué la
Fondation Nicolas Hulot faisait en mai
2011 une estimation de 600 milliards
d'euros sur une décennie soit 3% du
produit intérieur brut à l'époque ça
reste quand même assez flou et ça reste
des montants aussi assez élevés mais on
parlait que d'une décennie sur cette
enquête de la Fondation Nicolas Hulot
aujourd'hui vous trouvez que le
gouvernement met les moyens alors
aujourd'hui il y a il y a tout un
travail qui est fait sur le débat
national où on se pose des questions
comment aller vers une efficacité
énergétique c'est les grands thèmes qui
sont posés par les grandes idées qui
sont débattues pendant ce débat comment
aller vers l'efficacité énergétique
quelle trajectoire pour atteindre un mix
énergétique c'est-à-dire pour pour
s'équilibrer avec toutes ces nouvelles
énergies je vous rappelle que le
Président de la République a dit que
pour l'électricité on devrait descendre
en 2025 à 50 % d'énergie de d'origine
nucléaire alors qu'aujourd'hui on est
proche des 80 % pour l'électricité
chantée ce sont des déclarations est-ce
que ça vous semble faisable concrètement
est-ce que c'est pas utopique c'est il
faut il faut aller vers l’uranium toute
façon un jour on en manquera donc on
peut aussi attendre qu'il n'y ait plus
d'énergie pour faire quelque chose mais
là ça deviendra dramatique donc il faut
il faut anticiper et de toute cette
thématique vous allez l'évoquer ils en
savent bien sûr question lors du débat
de la conférence que vous organisez le
15 avril aujourd'hui pour des
particuliers qui nous écouteraient ou
ceux qui vont se rendre sur la
conférence qui est qui est prévu il
existe des dispositifs des moyens
d'accompagner les gens qui voudraient se
lancer dans cette transition énergétique
changer leur mode d'énergie alors ça va
être l'objet justement de notre débat
public là on fait intervenir des gens de
la région des gens plus locaux comme lac
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et Robert
catalbert des gens à qui on va poser les
questions comment on fait concrètement
au niveau du citoyen qui veut
arranger sa maison enfin isoler sa
maison auront des réponses s'ils se
rendent le 15 avril à Montigny voilà ils
ont des chances d'avoir des réponses
enfin ils poseront les questions et on
leur expliquera comment faire quels sont
les pièges à éviter par exemple quand on
veut isoler son pavillon ou son logement
comment on peut faire quoi quels sont
les pistes l'idée aussi c'est de
recueillir quelques témoignages
peut-être quelques pistes est-ce que
vous allez essayer de deux regrouper au
sein peut-être d'un livre blanc qui
pourrait servir pour la communauté
d'agglomération ou même être transmis
puisque le Grenelle de l'environnement
envisageait alors ces débats au niveau
national oui il y a déjà un débat qui a
été conduit par au niveau de la
casquille qui a eu lieu vendredi dernier
je crois qu'il y a qui a fait monter un
certain nombre d'idées qui vont être
remontés au niveau du débat national
nous le but de notre débat public c'est
vraiment d'informer le citoyen de lui
faire de nouveau prendre conscience du
problème à régler dans les dans les
années à venir et
également lui donner des pistes de pour
résoudre ces problèmes quel est le but
premier de votre association alors c'est
de mener ce genre de débat c'est de
mener ce genre de débat c'est
l'association c'est
association citoyenne Montigny autrement
c'est d'essayer de lancer des débats
comme ça et de participer à des débats
en insistant sur le mot autrement pour
dire il y a peut-être d'autres solutions
auxquelles on n'a pas pensé et donc en
dialoguant avec les citoyens on risque
de trouver parfois des solutions
auxquelles on n'a pas pensé dans tous
les cas le dialogue est nécessaire
vous-même vous êtes bénévoles au sein de
cette association vous allez mise en
place avec d'autres d'autres bénévoles
qu'est-ce qui vous a motivé à vous
lancer sur ces problématiques sur ces
questions ce débat de politique disons
globale locale en fait c'est ça l'idée
que au niveau d'une cité comme Montigny
ou comme une agglomération il faut du
débat avec les citoyens on ne peut pas
laisser les gens en place seuls
s'occuper des affaires ils ont besoin
aussi de du dialogue avec la population
et on est un peu dans ce dans cette
optique est-ce que vous l'avez fait vous
cette transition énergétique vous l'avez
faite j'ai commencé
légèrement j'allais dire en faisant en
mettant une isolation double vitrage
mais en consultant la lettre l'agence
locale après je me suis aperçu que
j'aurais dû commencer par isoler ma
toiture vous avez d'autres perspectives
d'autres évolutions prévues vers la
toiture sans doute voilà quelques-uns
des conseils peut-être que vous pourrez
que vous donnerez peut-être sans doute
leurs deux elle se rendez vous
transition énergétique lundi à 15 avril
20h club le village à Montigny le
Bretonneau merci à vous d'être venu en
parler merci Gérard